salut dans ce c normand s'intéresse à un
produit qu'on utilise tous enfin en
théorie c'est la brosse à dents partir
d'un endroit sur le tour de toutes tes
dents et revenir à ton point de départ
bonjour bien loin de la chine et des
brosses à dents en plastique
nous voici chez hgrégoire guillou
tournerait bénisti fabricant de
procédant en bois
ça ce sont des petites briques de bois
et c'est là que commence l'aventuré de
la crosada rebattu cotentin c'est ça
c'est ça part vite d'une planche de bois
on débite des carrelets donc ça c'est du
chêne ont fait des quarts les deux
centimètres par deux centimètres on
débite et puis après on va pouvoir les
tournées
balleux
le chêne un peu plus cassants c'est plus
fibre ou quoi mais sinon ça se travaille
à peu près pareil
et cette brosse à dents on la retrouve
ensuite dans les magasins de luxe ou les
suites vip les grands hôtels
je me suis dit que ça est très pratique
avec le support en bois pour le poser
sur le lavabo et je trouvais que ça
avait un côté assez à la fois masculin
ou féminin vous pouvez plaire aussi ces
deux types de ces deux types de
personnes et que savait à peu près sa
place dans n'importe quel type de
l'univers ou d'intérieur en slidant je
suis le concepteur du projet à la base
de l'idée est donc après j'ai réuni
autour de moi tout un
tout un tas d'intervenants de sous
traitants d'associer etc
et donc voilà vous en était à la partie
manche et donc dans ce moment je viens
bien se vit c'est en fait la tête de la
brosse à dents dans laquelle en fait
vient ensuite se clipser les poils donc
on a une brosse à dent en trois parties
alors ça s'est fait dans le
nord-cotentin exactement ça c'est fait
ça s'est fait dans la région de lyon
voilà et les poils français aussi alors
les poils malheureusement sont pas
français les poils viennent d'italie
parce qu'il reste qu'un seul industriel
de la brosse à dents en france et qui
n'était pas en mesure de fabriquer cette
tête là donc on avait vraiment une
volonté de faire du made in france au
début 100% made in france
malheureusement il ya des choses qu'on
peut plus produire en france notamment
cette tête de voir sa griffe vendue l'an
chou est un chef d'entreprise nomades
son point d'ancrage l' espace de
coworking déchire bout en cotentin mon
entreprise au jour d'aujourd'hui elles
se résument essentiellement mon
ordinateur et mon téléphone
c'est vrai que c'est assez mobile et
c'est sympa de venir travailler dans un
endroit comme strates wade et avec
d'autres gens des freelancer qui sont un
petit peu non
cap sur comment l'ingénieur de formation
a eu la bonne idée et s'est engouffré
dans un marché de niche non en fait sur
le territoire français on a le brevet de
du système de clip commence à vous est
venue alors l'idée de départ en fait
elle est née de la découverte de brosses
à dents du 19e siècle dans un grenier en
normandie donc on revient toujours un
peu la normandie au 19ème c'était des
brosses à dents soit en ivoire soit en
hausse et les gens faisaient leurs poils
et l'embrassa dont il avait toujours au
moins deux mort et sa non une qui était
en train de se faire au poil est et du
poids l'âge à la main et déjà à l'époque
en fait on changeait que les poils de la
brosse à dents le point de départ de
l'idée ça a été ça la fin du jetable
c'est le pari de grégoire lanchon ses
brosses à dents en bois ou en plastique
peuvent être utilisés dix ans il suffit
de changer les têtes achetable sur
internet
l'idée est de développer cette habitude
de consommation
on a voulu aussi élargir notre cible
pour en faisant découvrir cette brosse à
dents est interchangeable alors au plus
de monde possible donc ça me rend cela
les disponible à 15 euros à la vente
notamment à celles ci qui sont
disponibles à 55 euros
ni électrique ni à ultrasons ni
connectés mais ici aux produits
écologiques artisanale et design aux
soupes
tu vois que tu vas bien nettoyer le
sillon givaudan terre et les espaces
interdentaires du made in france
écologique
la brosse à dents calicots tentera de
conquérir le monde voilà c'est normand
c'est fini à la semaine prochaine